The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality,
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Why don't we
go ahead and get going.
Today what we want
to do is talk about
predator/prey interactions.
In particular, how a predator
and its associated prey
can in principal
oscillate over time.
Now in this area there's this
very important model block,
a Volterra model,
that has been used
as kind of the standard model.
It's given us some intuition
for how this might happen.
But mathematical
biologists really
don't like this model very
much, because the oscillations
that it give are neutral,
or neutrally stable
cycles or orbits.
What I mean is that
it's not a limit cycle.
It doesn't have a characteristic
amplitude, nor a period.
And associated with that--
and it's not a concidence--
and associated with
it, what it means
is that if you make sort
of very small modifications
to the model, then you can
get qualitatively different
outcomes.
In particular, you can either
abolish the cycles-- i.e.,
you can turn these
neutrally stable orbits
into stable limits--
or I'm sorry.
Into a stable spiral.
So it may have damped
the oscillations.
So it could be that the
oscillations kind of go away
over time.
Or it could be that you turn
them into true limit cycle
oscillations.
And this could just be from
very small changes in the model.
That's associated with this
fact that the logical Volterra
model was neutrally stable.
Then we'll kind of
switch gears a little bit
and talk about
these experiments--
that Yoshida paper that you
guys read-- where they looked
at this question of what
happens in kind of a laboratory
experiment where you have
a predator and its prey.
And in particular
what they found
is that if there is evolution
in the prey population,
that you can get qualitatively
different oscillations
in particular.
Instead of having a 90 degree
phase shift between predator
and prey, you can end
up with 180 degrees
phase shift, so kind of
anti-correlated oscillations.
But also that the oscillations
could be much longer than what
you'd.
Expect
And finally we'll
say something about
these noise-induced
oscillations, which
I believe that
you guys have been
playing with a bit in the
context of your homework.
Is it the next one?
Oh, I get it.
Well, you will get a chance
to play with a great deal.
So pay attention then.
All right.
Any questions
before we get going?
Problem set's due tomorrow so
that you can enjoy Thanksgiving
with your family or friends.
And then we'll have
one more problem set.
So this Lotka-Volterra model.
There's kind of a
fun history of this,
which I'll tell you about.
But I just want to
highlight that there
are two important things that
you should be remembering.
And I'm getting these two
points from Mark Kot in his book
Elements of Theoretical
Ecology, where
he says there are two things you
need to know about this model.
One is that it's a bad model.
And of course you can
argue what you mean by bad.
I think it's maybe
overstating it.
But we'll try to be explicit
about why he might say that.
But then it's sort of
profoundly important.
He kind of says from a
historical perspective.
But I would say that maybe
both of these statements
are sort of true.
It's a bad model
mathematically in some ways,
because it's somehow
structurally unstable, but also
profoundly important.
The mark of
intelligence is being
able to keep two incompatible
ideas in your mind
at the same time.
Somebody said
something like that.
More than two?
OK.
Well, we'll try to figure
out what we mean by this.
All right.
So Kot, it's a nice book
on mathematical ecology,
if you're curious.
The history of this is that
it was in the mid-1920s.
And there was a marine biologist
named Humberto D'Ancona.
Does anybody speak Italian?
Well, he was a marine biologist.
And he had been studying the
prevalence of different fish
species in fish markets, and
kind of throughout Italy.
So he went to fish markets.
Over the course of about
R-K. For about 10 years.
Right?
So kind of roughly
from 1912 to 1923.
Something like that.
And he basically
asked, well, what
is the kind of the
composition of fish
being sold in all these
fish markets across Italy.
And he noticed something
that was very interesting,
which is that there was a
marked change in the composition
between more predatory
fish as compared
to more prey-like fish.
And this was associated with
something that was happening
in Europe around that time.
World War I. OK.
So World War I in the middle.
And what he found was that
in the middle of this period
there was an increase,
and then later a decrease
of what he called selachians,
which is apparently
a word for sharks
and shark-like fish.
But for our purposes, we'll
just say they are typically
kind of predators.
So what he saw is that
this number of selachians,
a function of time, kind
of went like this, right.
Where this was kind of
roughly World War I.
And he wanted to try to
understand why did this happen.
Why is it that war
favors predators?
Probably not just having to
do with the general zeitgeist
at the time.So it's probably a
more mechanistic explanation.
And luckily, Humberto was
engaged to the beautiful Luisa
Volterra.
OK.
Oops.
Engaged to Luisa Volterra.
So one day mid-1920s,
our hero Humberto
was visiting his girlfriend.
And he started chatting with
his future father-in-law, who
was Vito Volterra, and
asked him this question.
And luckily, Vito Volterra
was a famous mathematician.
So he could write
down a fancy model
and try to get some
insight into this question.
So this is a case of random
personal interaction leading
to something interesting.
That's the Volterra--
Lotka had actually
studied these equations
almost 15 years earlier.
First in the context of auto
catalytic kind of chemical
reactions and so forth.
But then later indeed, in the
context of population dynamics.
So Lotka wrote a book
in the mid-1920s.
Volterra wrote an article
analyzing D'Ancona's data.
And then now it's called
the Lotka-Volterra model.
And we'll come
back to this thing
about why is it that war
favors predators after we
get a sense of the model.
So what Volterra wrote
down was the following.
First of all, we should all
make sure we can figure out
which one is the predator
and which one is the prey.
So let's think about
this for 15 seconds.
And then we're going to
yell it out verbally.
Is y the predator or the prey?
Ready, three, two, one.
AUDIENCE: Predator.
PROFESSOR: Predator.
All right.
So we have a predator
here and prey.
Is the total size
of the population
constant? i.e, is x plus
y equal to a constant?
Ready, yes or no.
Verbally.
Three, two, one.
No.
It would be a constant
perhaps if these two terms--
if b were equal to d or so.
No.
That's not even true.
Never mind.
Yeah.
OK.
I guess really what
I'm thinking about is
this tells us about
how many predators can
be created from a prey.
But then there's also
the growth in death rate.
All right.
But even this act
of converting prey
into a predator,
even on that level
it's not conserved, right?
And of course, vegetarians
like to point out
that you can create many corn
burgers for the price of making
a hamburger.
Something like that.
OK.
Except in the case of salmon.
This is not true.
Well, all right.
We can analyze the
ratio of d over b
for a variety of
different newt sandwiches
after class, perhaps.
OK.
So this is pretty much
the simplest model
you can kind of
possibly write down
that captures this basic
idea that when these two
species interact, we're assuming
that there's this mass action
kind of rate.
That it's just
proportional to the number
of the density of x and y.
Now I think that in the
context of chemical reactions,
this is going to be true over
a huge range of densities,
and perhaps almost
even rigorously true
if they are just single.
There's just some x and y
that bounce into each other.
And at some rate
they do something.
Whereas I think in the
context of predator and prey,
this is on much
less firm footing.
That's OK.
So it's at least the simplest
thing we can write down.
And of course, then we'll
have to ask, how is it
that the conclusions
of the model
might vary depending on the
assumptions that go in here.
One thing that we've spent a
lot of time in this class doing
is trying to look at a set
of equations, and in words,
be able to extract what the
assumptions were that went
into writing the equation.
And associated
with that, you can
think about all these things
about the nondimensionalized
versions of these equations.
You'll often see the
predator/prey models written
in some nondimensionalized
version, where for example, you
get rid of maybe the
a and maybe the c.
I think that in
many cases I prefer
to just leave these terms in
here, because that way we can
immediately see what
happens if we go hunting,
or if we do this or that.
OK.
Can we try to figure
out what-- there
are four assumptions,
at least, that
have gone into this that are
relevant and are worth saying.
Can you guys help me out?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It's well-mixed.
The interaction in
terms of [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
Right.
So it's well-mixed.
And there's two aspects that
we might-- So one thing,
it is certainly worth
saying that it's well-mixed.
But associated with
that, you're going to say
that it's because of x times y.
Right?
Yeah.
I guess that's what I feel
you were about to say.
AUDIENCE: I mean, I guess.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Right I guess.
But I think we have to keep
these things a little bit
separate in the
context of chemistry,
those are maybe the
same statements, right?
Of course, we're
writing these things.
These are just quantities that
are just functions of time.
We have not included
space explicitly.
So in that sense, it's
definitely a well-mixed model.
But just because we're
assuming that it's well-mixed,
we're not keeping track
of the state of density
as a function of
position does not
mean that they have to
interact with this term.
And for two molecules that are
bouncing against each other,
then I think that is the case.
But we have to keep these
assumptions separate.
AUDIENCE: You could imagine
a colony of bacteria,
for example, where
they're all-- you can only
prey on the outside.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Necessary.
I guess what I would say is
that if it were not well-mixed,
it could still be that
they interact like this.
And you just keep track of
the predator/prey density
as a function of position.
And they could still interact
in this way, possibly.
And in particular, in the
context of Turing patterns,
what we did is we
allowed these things
to vary as a
function of position.
But then we would have
still typically written
the interaction
term as x times y.
So it is true
we're modeling this
as a well-mixed population.
But I think that's
independent of this statement.
Do you agree or disagree?
Or?
AUDIENCE: But if
it's well-mixed,
the encounter frequency will
be proportional to [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: That's sort
of the secret, right?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: The assumption
is the encounter frequency
is proportionate, right?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
OK.
So what I would say
is-- well, certainly
in the context of
predators and prey,
it could be that if
the prey is full,
then it's not going
to be so simple.
In a sense, is that I
guess it could be more
complicated than that is all.
But my statement--
AUDIENCE: So you're saying--
I'm sorry-- the interaction
term would not necessarily be
just a function of x times y.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
It could be more
complicated than that.
And the other thing is that
even if it were not well-mixed,
in the context of these
reaction diffusion models,
we would typically say that the
rate that these two things hit
each other is x times y.
But they're each a
function of position.
Right.
So it's not that there's--
it can either be well-mixed
or not.
And it can either
be this or not.
I guess.
AUDIENCE: But it's not
quite the same variable,
because in that case it would
be the density, whereas--
PROFESSOR: I agree.
Although here, it's not
obvious whether we're
talking about number
or density, frankly.
Right.
And we often talk about this as
if it's the number of predator,
number of prey.
But then that's a little bit
inconsistent with this in that
if you were-- this
should really be,
if you're thinking about
these terms being the product.
And it should really
be the density.
And if you're looking
at the population
size in some fixed area or
volume, then it doesn't matter.
But even in the context
of predator or prey,
I'd say that the way in
which this would make senses
is via densities.
Does this discussion make sense?
Maybe?
We are assuming it's
well-mixed, because we're not
thinking about these things
as a function of position.
But I would say that we
cannot get that from just
the interaction term.
We are assuming it's
well-mixed, though.
Other things that
we've assumed here?
AUDIENCE: Something along
the lines of the prey
doesn't need the
predator, for instance.
PROFESSOR: Right.
The prey does not
need the predator.
And in particular, what
happens to the prey
in the absence of predator?
AUDIENCE: It grows.
PROFESSOR: So the prey
grows exponentially.
AUDIENCE: Because it's
not diet [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Without predator.
And the other thing
that is perhaps worth
mentioning in all this
though is that this
is a deterministic
description of the world.
So a here is telling us about--
the normal way that we would
interpret a is it's the rate
of division of the cells,
or the rate of new deer
being born, or whatnot.
But of course, a
could actually be
the difference between this
growth rate and a death rate.
So just because we don't
have an explicit death rate
doesn't mean that
there's no death.
So I think you can't actually
say that the prey does not
die in the absence of predator.
What you can say is that
the prey population--
we're assuming that
a is greater than 0.
So what you can say is that
the prey population grows
exponentially without
the predator at rate a.
But this is really in
principle the difference
between the growth rate and
the death rate of the prey
in the absence of the predator.
And in the context of a
differential equation,
this doesn't make
any difference.
But if we were to go and do a
master equation type formalism,
would this make a difference?
Yeah.
Right.
So this is the whole thing about
the Fokker-Planck approach.
And you can get different
variances at equilibrium,
depending on whether the rate
of forward back reactions and so
forth.
Does that sound
familiar to you guys?
No.
What else have we
assumed in this model?
AUDIENCE: The predator
dies exponentially.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So the predator dies
exponentially when?
exponentially without the prey.
So it's a nice
simple assumption.
Other things that you might
like to point out about this?
AUDIENCE: A single
predator is [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
Right.
So there is a sense that
it's just x times y.
So the most simple way
to think about this
is that it somehow is a single
predator eating a single prey.
There's maybe no group
hunting type behavior.
So if we wanted to try to
understand how a pack of wolves
can bring down a
buffalo, then you
might not want to
use this equation.
So this is that the
rate of predation
is proportional-- we'll
say goes as x times y.
And that embodies many
different kinds of assumptions.
These are four findings.
OK.
So since it's such a simple
model, we can go ahead
and we can just solve it.
Right.
How many fixed points
are there going to be?
Two.
OK.
It's always good to
remember these things.
And so what we can
think about, this as x.
This is y.
There's indeed going to be a
fixed point somewhere in here.
But then the other one is
going to be at zero, zero.
Because the top equation
has x's everywhere.
Bottom equation
has y's everywhere.
So indeed, there's going to be
one fixed point at zero,zero.
So-called the
trivial fixed point.
Is this a stable, or is this
an unstable fixed point?
Let's think about
this for a moment.
And then we'll vote verbally.
Stable or unstable?
OK.
Ready, three, two, one.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So I think there
were some disagreements there
probably.
It was a little hard to
tell from the verbal.
And one way that we can
think about this as that we
can ask, well, the predator in
the absence of the prey, what
happens to it?
So it kind of comes down here.
So along this axis it's stable.
However, in the
absence of predator,
if you think about the
prey, that'll grow.
So this is actually an
unstable fixed point.
Stable along one axis and
unstable on the other.
Incidentally, what
does this tell us
about the eigenvectors
around this fixed point?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: That's right.
The eigenvectors are
really just 0, 1, 1, 0.
Because you can see that if
you start along one of these,
you come straight down.
Start along the other one,
And the other one we
can just see by-- well,
we can solve it directly.
Just we pull out an x.
It's when a minus
by is equal to zero.
And also when minus c
plus dx is equal to zero.
So the other fixed point,
this x star, y star, and this
is maybe the important one.
It's going to be just
c over d and a over b.
Super simple model.
Right?
You can calculate
where the fixed
points are kind of immediately.
But it's actually a model that
has many weird properties.
Some of which you might
think of as features.
Some of which you
might think of as bugs.
But in particular, the location
of this fixed point, I think,
is really sort of surprising
in that its dependence on this
abcd.
This is part of
why I really think
that when analyzing this
model, I very much prefer
to keep the a's, b's, c's,
d's, rather than using
the nondimensionalized
version of it.
Because when you do that, you
lose track of what's going on.
So this model for example,
makes very clear predictions
of what should happen if
you hunt the predator.
There are various contexts
in which wildlife managers
have been interested in trying
to help a prey population.
So if a prey population
is suffering in some way,
then you can reasonably think
what you should want to do
is kill the predator.
And this is all these debates
where you have the wildlife
managers, where they buy
automatic rifles in order
to shoot wolves
from helicopters.
We have a Canadian
in the room, right?
I mean, wasn't this
a Canadian proposal?
AUDIENCE: I'm very American.
PROFESSOR: All right.
We'll have to do some more
research to figure out exactly.
OK.
Right.
So the question is, well, what
happens at least in this model?
And people apparently
have seen this sort
of thing occurring in natural
populations as well, right?
If you hunt the predator by
going out and shooting them,
what does this do to the
predator and the prey
populations.
In particular, we think
about x star, y star.
Well maybe this-- am I confused?
Maybe this is the example
that I'm confused by.
Well we have to complete
it now that I started it.
But now I might
have gone backwards.
We'll see what happens,
and then discuss.
All right.
Ready.
Three-- Oh wait.
I don't have enough options.
OK.
Sorry.
We should do one,
then the other.
Because sometimes things
don't change, right?
So how do I do this?
OK.
Sorry.
We should just do one,
then the other, right?
No change.
This is down.
OK.
There's gonna be a
problem [INAUDIBLE].
Let's first do y star.
Cause that's the
most direct one.
Sorry.
I think that my story
I got backwards.
But we'll figure this out.
OK.
Ready?
So the question is,
there's a population
that you want to-- all right.
Now I'm going to redo
my story to make it--
but there's a population you
want to keep in check somehow.
So you might reasonably
go out and shoot it.
Right?
So the question
is, if you go out
and you do this on
the predator, at least
in this model, what happens?
All right.
Ready.
Three, two, one.
Right.
So although we actually
have a fair number
of disagreements on this.
So we're actually kind
of 50-50 at this stage.
What is it if you go out
and from the helicopter,
you start shooting
this animal, what
does that do from the
standpoint of this model?
Right.
So we're shooting the predator.
a, b, c, d, what you think?
What should it change?
c.
And does c go up or go down?
C goes up.
OK.
Well, how does
that affect y star?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Right.
You know, I mean, I'm thinking
daily helicopter rides
where you shoot wolves
as you see them.
AUDIENCE: This is Canada.
PROFESSOR: This is Canada.
This is Canada.
Yeah, those Canadians.
AUDIENCE: So effectively,
you're changing the death rate
of-- that's what you're saying.
PROFESSOR: Well, OK.
So that's my claim.
Of course, all of these things
can be more complicated.
But it certainly is
change in the death rate
when you go and shoot them.
So I guess I would say
that in the context
of this model, that's the
simplest way to think about it.
So the statement is that
if you hunt this predator,
you're increasing the death
rate for the predator.
You're increasing c.
Hunting predator.
This causes c to go up.
And the striking thing is
that y star does not change.
OK.
AUDIENCE: I believe you.
I think it's funny.
PROFESSOR: OK.
[LAUGHS] You believe me.
OK, I'm glad.
One thing is believing me in
the context of this model.
Another thing is asking whether
this is happening in real life.
But I think people have
seen such weird phenomenon
in the context.
But then of course,
it's a matter
of is this a dominant source?
What's going on?
Like many, many things.
Right.
But certainly in
this model, there's
this weird phenomenon where
the death rate of the predator
does not alter this y star.
OK.
We have to figure out what the
y star means here in a moment.
What is the effect on
this fixed point number
concentration of the prey?
It goes up.
So my original story, I
think I was getting confused.
So at least in
this model there's
a sense that if you
hunt the predator,
it's true that you don't
bring down the steady state,
or the time average-- we'll
see-- time averaged number
of the predator population.
But you do increase
the prey population.
Because in this case
you can help the prey.
But you don't bring
down the predator.
Now I want to say something
more about justifying
this thing about why we might
care about x star and y star
so much.
So this thing is x star/y star.
Well, maybe all.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: As soon as
you stop shooting,
this is a very
temporary solution.
When you stop shooting, c goes
back to its original value.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
When you stop
shooting, c goes back
to its original model,
or original value.
And then the prey population
will come back down.
So this is something you
have to continue to do.
Yes.
What do I wanna say?
If you go ahead
and you calculate
the-- if we linearize around
this fixed point x star/y
star, that's our standard
thing that we did early
on the semester, what we
find is that this Jacobian,
this matrix A, the linearized
matrix you get is-- all right.
Well, we come here and we take
the derivative with respect
to x.
So we get a minus by.
Derivative of this guy
up top with respect to y.
And we get minus bx.
And derivative of this g
function with respect to x.
We get dy.
Now aspect to y, we
have a minus c plus dx.
Now we want to evaluate
this around that fixed point
at x star/y star,
which is given here.
We plug this in.
So evaluate at y star.
It's a over b 0.
Evaluate at x star.
This is just minus bc over d.
Now y star, this is ab over b.
And here we can get 0.
So this is telling us about
the linearized dynamics
around a fixed
point x star/y star.
Now for this sort of matrix,
what are the eigenvalues?
It's not that the
eigenvalues are 0.
It's a slightly
different statement.
What are the eigenvalues
for a matrix like this?
What's that?
AUDIENCE: They're imaginary.
PROFESSOR: Right.
They're purely imaginary.
So the real part
is equal to zero.
So indeed, we can
figure out this.
Cause remember, to figure
out what the eigenvalues are,
you take the determinant
of this vector
a minus this lambda times
the identity matrix.
So we end up with, we want to
take the determinant of-- we
have a minus lambda,
a minus lambda,
and then minus bc over d.
This is lambda squared.
And then this is a plus, we
have bc over d, ab over b.
So we end up that
the eigenvalues
are equal to plus minus
square root of a times ci.
So they're purely
imaginary eigenvalues.
And what does this mean again?
What can you say when you
do this sort of analysis
and you have purely
imaginary eigenvalues?
AUDIENCE: The orbits look
like ellipses or something
like that.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So the statement is that-- OK.
And then we have to be careful
in all of this business.
So what we've done
is we've taken
a set of non-linear, a pair
of non-linear differential
equations.
We've done the linear
stability analysis.
And we get purely imaginary.
So one thing that you can
say is that if you started
with a linear
system, and you got
purely imaginary eigenvalues,
that would tell you
that indeed, you have these
neutrally stable orbits,
they go around.
They can have a variety
of different shapes.
But given that the order
that we did things in
is that we took a
nonlinear system,
and we linearized,
and then got this.
What does that allow you to say?
Does that prove
that you actually
have these neutrally
stable [INAUDIBLE]?
Yeah.
Because this is one
of those border cases,
it unfortunately
does not actually
allow you to say that you
have neutrally stable orbits.
Because it turns out that
the slight nonlinearities
in the equations
could cause problems,
and cause it to go either
to a stable limit cycle
or to a stable spiral.
The confusing thing
is that in this case
it is true that you have
neutrally stable orbits.
But that did not
have to be true.
And guys will get the chance
to do this proof and so forth.
Because there some
conserved quantities.
Of course, people have analyzed
this thing in more depth.
And it is true that you have
neutrally stable orbits.
But what is very
hard to remember
is that it didn't have
to be the case just based
on what we've said so far.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned,
it's not a coincidence.
There is a deeper reason why?
PROFESSOR: Well, coincidence.
I guess what I'm
saying is that you
can prove that this
thing does have
these neutrally stable orbits.
But we have not proven that.
And we're not going to.
Do these orbits go around
clockwise or counterclockwise?
Ready.
Three, two, one.
AUDIENCE: Counterclockwise.
PROFESSOR: Counterclockwise.
Right.
And you can get that
from thinking about what
predator and prey should do.
But also I've already
drawn some arrows here.
And that kind of helps
provide some guidance.
So they kind of come
around like this.
Now is this the only orbit
that I should be drawing here?
No.
Right.
Because it turns out
that in this case
there are an
infinitely large number
of orbits that could
possibly come around.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Well, in the context
of our simulation,
the simplest thing that
you guys would probably do
is you would simulate and
see what comes around.
But yeah.
I think even in the
reading, did they prove it?
Different authors in different
books either prove it or don't.
And there are a
number of different--
you'll see in the
problems, you can
find that there is a
quantity that is conserved
along the equations of motion.
But the quantity's different
for each of these orbits.
Right.
So it's really saying
that as you go,
there's some
quantities conserved.
And it still has the same
value when you go around.
And so that means you
had to kind of come back
to where you were.
So there is a
conserved quantity.
You'll see it.
Now these neutrally
stable orbits
are kind of funny
in several ways.
Well, first of all,
this eigenvalue
tells you about the
period of the orbits
when you're close
to the fixed point.
And you can see that
it doesn't depend
on everything in the model.
It depends on a and c.
Does that kind of
make sense, maybe?
Yeah.
Sort of.
Cause a is telling us about
how rapidly we grow up here.
c is talking about how
rapidly we die over here.
So you know, it has
something that at least
has units of 1 over time.
It makes sense that a
and c should appear here.
But I would submit that it's
not totally obvious that b
and d should not appear at all.
So neutrally stable
orbits, there's
no characteristic amplitude to
the oscillations, nor period.
And this is at least true
far from the fixed point.
This tells you about
maybe these orbits.
But then it doesn't tell you
about what happens far away.
And these are not the
kind of oscillations
that from a
mathematical standpoint
we like the most,
which are limit cycles.
And remember, a limit
cycle would look like this.
If it were a limit
cycle, it would
be that there's some orbit
that is stable in the sense
that if you start
inside of it, then
you would approach it over time.
If you start outside
of it, then again,
you would approach it over time.
And this orbit then would have
a characteristic amplitude,
and a characteristic period,
because it's one orbit.
Whereas here, this has
kind of an infinite number
of different orbits.
What this means is
that just any sort
of noise-- demographic
fluctuations and so forth--
would cause the system to
drift over time in terms
of this amplitude of period.
So it's true that if
you got it started
in the absence of
any noise, it would
keep on doing that oscillation
forever with that amplitude.
But any random noise will
cause the thing to drift.
The other thing that
is worth stressing
in this is that if you do a
time average of the predator
concentration, or the
prey concentration,
so if you do the average or the
mean, x as a function of time,
or y is a function of time
is indeed x star y star.
That's also something
that you'd have to show.
Not at all obvious from this.
It's not a surprise for these
orbits that are out here that
the time average is
indeed x star /y star.
But for these big orbits,
they probably already
didn't have to be.
So this is telling us that the
analysis that we were talking
about-- well, what
happens if you
do one thing or another
thing-- that's actually
kind of a reasonable quantity
to be trying to calculate,
because that is the
average or the mean number
of predator/prey in this model.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So in a
zombie apocalypse,
how do we thin down
the zombie [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes.
That's a very
important question.
In the event of a
zombie apocalypse,
what do we have to do
in order to thin out
the zombie population?
All right.
Well, the zombie
movies typically
are not yet at equilibrium.
But certainly at equilibrium,
what do you want to do?
This is not a formal
recommendation, by the way.
But in this model, if
you want to decrease
the number of the predator,
what is it that we want to do?
Right.
Well, OK.
So in this model, if
you want to decrease
the number of the
zombies at equilibrium,
you want to decrease a,
which corresponds to--
AUDIENCE: So it's
a is equal to 0.
So the birth rate is
equal to the death rate,
then there aren't new zombies.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
There are probably
also no people.
AUDIENCE: But there are.
The birth rate is
equal to the-- so you
have a stable population.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So in the limit, as
a goes to 0, it's
true that the number
of zombies goes to 0.
AUDIENCE: So you just
have to beat [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes.
This is a good
situation where it's
important to ask about whether
your assumptions in the model
are good before making
public policy based on them.
OK?
Indeed.
But can we go back
just for a moment
before we switch gears, to
ask about this question of why
it was that war might have
favored these predator fish?
And by favored, what
he really measured,
he measured the number
of the frequency
of these kind of predator
fish at the markets.
So it's somehow is maybe the
ratio of those two, or so.
Yeah.
That's right.
Yes, it could that the
fisherman just-- yeah.
So they could have fished
in a different region.
And so the explanation
could be something--
AUDIENCE: Because it's
not very well controlled.
PROFESSOR: It's not a
controlled experiment.
That's why you need to have
many different wars in order
to average the
importance of large data.
AUDIENCE: That's going to
be a great [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
And then of course,
in all this business
you have to ask, well, which
thing are you varying more
or less, et cetera, et cetera.
But let's say that
to first order,
the fishermen are
going out there
and they're just
catching all the fish
in an unbiased fashion.
But the war is making it
more difficult to fish.
So not as many fishermen go out.
And then what does that
do to these parameters?
Right.
So it might increase a,
because the prey are not
getting caught as much.
And it might do something
also to the predator.
What?
So the predator fish
are also being caught,
cause they're showing
up at the market.
Right.
So which other parameters
does it change?
So what's that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right.
So lets be clear.
It's a war makes a go down.
All right.
And what other
parameter might change?
AUDIENCE: Fewer fishermen.
PROFESSOR: Oh.
I'm sorry.
You're right.
I was starting to think
about the next one.
OK.
So a goes up.
And what also happens?
And c goes down.
And this is just because a is a
growth rate. c is a death rate.
So it's not that the
fishermen are preferentially
changing what they're
doing between the prey
fish and the predator
fish, but it's
just that these are
defined different ways.
Right?
And in particular, what this
means is that in times of war,
Voltaire's argument to
his future son-in-law
was that what you expect is that
the predator population should
go up.
And the prey population
should go down.
So the ratio of them
should certainly
shift in favor of the predator.
Or maybe it's just
that the fishermen
didn't go into the deep
regions of water or something,
where predator fish
like to hang out.
But it's striking at least
that a simple model like this
can actually provide
some insight.
Any questions about
where we are before we
modify the model in some way?
Now, the problem
with this model is
that it's making
lots of assumptions
that we very much
think are not true.
So we have a few of the
assumptions up there.
Which ones are you
guys least happy
about among those assumptions?
Yeah.
The second one, the prey
grows exponentially,
i.e., without bound.
That's not physical.
We should fix that.
So let's go ahead and do that.
All right.
So real prey populations-- and
all populations-- populations
saturate.
Don't go to infinity, right.
We can just make a quick
little fix to our model
to capture this, right?
X dot.
So now it's going to be this ax.
But what we can do is we can
add a logistic term here.
And we can leave
everything else constant.
So we just add this
logistic row term.
So now in the absence
of a predator, what
will happen is that the
prey population saturates
at some point, at some value k.
Right?
And k could be rather
large, if you like.
And I think this is
the kind of situation
where you say, oh
well, that could
be just a really modest change.
Because it's primarily
telling us about what
happens kind of in the
absence of the predator.
But really, the dynamics
around here could be unchanged.
But what's striking
is that because
of this neutral
stability of the model,
any little change can lead
to a qualitative change
in the outcome at equilibrium.
And in particular, adding
a carrying capacity
causes the sustained
oscillations to disappear.
Instead you get
damped oscillations.
So in this case, xy, you
still have this fixed point.
But what happens is that you
get-- it orbits the look.
Kind of like this.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah OK.
So that depends
upon [INAUDIBLE].
And indeed, as k
goes to infinity,
the timescale of this decay
goes to infinity as well.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
clean scaling.
PROFESSOR: A clean scaling.
AUDIENCE: But I mean
just [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: I mean, I don't have
nothing intelligent to say.
But what I can say is
that if you put in a k
at values that are close
to this fixed point,
then the oscillations
really disappear.
It's really only as
k goes way, way out.
And I maybe won't
do this calculation.
But you can do it quickly.
It's the kind of thing you can
do in five minutes on an exam
or so, right?
But then the question
you might ask me,
well what can you do in order to
get these oscillations that we
really like?
These sustained limit
cycle oscillations?
And there are two ways
you can think about this.
One is by a kind of
taking this sort of model
and adding features and
playing with it and so forth.
Or you can ask a mathematician
who kind of derives everything
in kind of totality.
And then you can see it.
I'll say that one thing you
can do on a concrete basis
to change the outcome of this
is you can add something that
is kind of like some
saturation effect
at the level of the interaction
between predator and prey.
So instead of scaling
purely as x times y,
if instead there some sort of
Michaelis-Menten type behavior
as a function of the
prey, then this model
is actually converted to one
that has a stable limit cycle.
And in this case,
can you guys remember
how you show that something
has a stable limit cycle?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
use the Poincare--
PROFESSOR: That's right.
There's this
Poincare-Bendixson theorem,
which tells us that if we
can draw some box out here
where the trajectories are all
kind of coming in, indeed, here
the trajectories are
kind of coming in.
Now in this case
the trajectories
have to come in everywhere.
But this is
typically true in any
of these reasonable systems.
Because they should, if there's
just not that much food,
they should be coming in.
Now in this case, there's
a single fixed point.
So then the question of
whether there's a limit cycle
is equivalent to the
question of the stability
of this interior fixed point.
It's a stable fixed point,
then all of these trajectories
will spiral in.
However, if it's an
unstable fixed point,
then you have to have a limit
cycle oscillation somewhere
in between.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: It could be that
it's a stable midpoint.
And then you have
two limit cycles.
Could that be?
PROFESSOR: Right.
So the question is whether
there can be a stable limit
cycle and two limit cycles.
I think that that requires
more fixed points.
Because let's say you
had a limit cycle here.
That this is saying that
the trajectories come in.
But it's also saying the
trajectories are coming out.
I think that you have to have
a fixed point inside here
in order to have these
trajectories going--
AUDIENCE: So what I'm
saying [INAUDIBLE]
two circles, and way
outside, all the trajectory
is [INAUDIBLE].
But between the two
circles, the trajectories
go from the outer circle
to the inner circle.
And then from the inner
circle in [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Are the circles
encircling each other?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So here's one circle.
Here's another circle.
And the trajectories
are coming into this one
and what are they doing?
AUDIENCE: So each of these limit
cycles are only semi-stable.
There are some--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
All right.
So you're talking about
these limit cycles
where the trajectories
come to it from one side,
but then leave from
the other side.
I'd have to think
about this more.
Everything that
I'm talking about
are the limit cycles that
are stable from both sides.
And I think that in the
presence of any amount of noise,
those are the only ones
that we care about.
Because you can write these
models where you have orbits
that are stable from one
side but not the other.
But then they don't
matter in any real system
that is subject to noise.
Because it's not a stable
orbit in that case, right?
AUDIENCE: Then we can make
the outer circle stable
from both sides, and the
inner circle [INAUDIBLE]
from both sides, and we
could get it [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK So it
could go like this.
So you're saying that
this outer orbit is now
stable from both sides.
And then this one is
unstable from here.
And oh, OK.
Now you're saying this thing
is unstable from-- so now
it's stable.
AUDIENCE: So we can have--
PROFESSOR: Yes.
OK.
So I can certainly
draw the trajectories,
as you pointed out.
And it works.
Yeah.
I don't know if
this is a loophole
in the wording of the theorem,
or if this is just not
possible.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] There's
like one way in which it
applies.
And then the other way
you kind of usually
think that it applies,
but then you're
wrong because there are
these counter examples.
PROFESSOR: I see.
Well, how about this.
I will look it up.
And then I will tell you
what I think the answer is.
I'm certainly not going to be
able to derive it on the spot.
But You're right, though.
I can draw the orbits
and they do it.
I don't know what that means.
AUDIENCE: So I
think the theorem is
if on this large circle
on the outside everything
is coming in, then if your
fixed point is unstable,
then you must have at least
one stable [INAUDIBLE] outside.
Or you must have at least
one that is [INAUDIBLE]
or something like that.
PROFESSOR: OK.
But you're saying that it--
AUDIENCE: But if you flip it
so the fixed point is stable,
then you could have--
PROFESSOR: I see.
That may be right.
I can't remember
which direction.
But I'll look it up.
But if you are curious about
the situations in which
these predator/prey functions
will have limit cycles,
you can look up
Kolmogorov's conditions.
So he basically has
these four conditions
in which you will
get a stable limit
cycle in the
predator/prey populations.
And maybe I will.
And they're surprisingly simple.
They were in the reading.
So you can look at them.
But they're basically just these
questions of the derivatives.
And they're derivatives of
the per capita growth rates.
So you take those
functions, you divide by x.
So it's x dot over x.
And then it's some f,
y dot over y, sub g.
And the derivatives of
those functions withe
respect to x and y
have to be something,
at least in some limits.
And then you get limit cycles.
But I want to talk
about the experiments.
Because I think that
they were quite pretty.
So this is a paper
by Yoshida, et al.
This is Nature 2003.
And the title was "Rapid
Evolution Drives Ecological
Dynamics in a
Predator/ Prey System."
Could somebody kind
of say what they think
is the big point of this paper?
Do you guys like the
paper, dislike the paper?
Too long?
Was it three pages?
Although it's really only--
I mean, one of the pages
is figures.
And one of the pages
is essentially methods.
So it's really basically
a one-page paper,
so it's not such
heavy lifting, maybe.
All right.
Maybe I'll be concrete.
What features of their
predator/prey oscillations
were different from a normal
predator/prey oscillation?
What were the features they
were trying to explain?
AUDIENCE: There's a longer
phase life between the maximum.
PROFESSOR: And this is an
interesting history, actually,
that these are authors-- they
took what I think are basically
like samples from the Great
Lakes, or something like that.
So they took a
predator and prey.
So it's a rotifer algal system.
So the rotifer eats algae.
They had previously published a
paper just a few years before,
where it was called
something like "Crossing
the Hopf Bifurcation in
a Predator/Prey System."
And so what they did is
they had a chemostat where
there was some constant rate
of dilution in their chemostat.
And then they measured the
dynamics between the predator
and the prey.
And they showed
that depending upon,
for example, the
nutrients or this dilution
rate in their chemostat, they
could go from a situation
where you have a
stable coexistence--
so a stable fixed point
between the predator/prey--
but at increasing dilution
rate, they started
getting these oscillations.
So they went from
stable to oscillations.
And then at higher
dilution rates,
they got collapse of this
predator/prey system.
So this is crossing the
so-called Hopf bifurcation,
where you go from
stable to unstable.
So they could actually see that
they could use a simple model
to try to get some
insight into why
it is that a predator/prey
system might oscillate
or it might not oscillate.
And so that was great.
But there were some
features in their data
that they didn't understand.
So the features were
that the oscillations
had a really long period.
Long period oscillations.
And in all this data,
it's a little bit hard
to get the exact phase lag,
but in many of the cases
they saw that the
predator and prey were not
at this 90 degrees out of
phase like you would expect.
And in particular,
for the predator/prey,
given that you have x and y, and
it's going around some circle,
the idea is that first
the prey population peaks.
And then kind of 90
degrees later phase,
you get a peak of the predator.
And you can imagine that
in any predator/prey model
that you write down,
not just Lotka-Volterra,
but if you write down
a differential equation
with some x and some y,
it's hard to get something
where it looks much different.
Of course, you can imagine
maybe funny orbits or something
like that.
But generically you really
expect this 90 degree phase
lag of the predator
relative to the prey.
Whereas in the
experiments, they often
saw 180 degree lag, lack of
predator relative to the prey.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So when you
say [INAUDIBLE] theory
of oscillation,
what does that mean?
What's the time scale?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What would make
this suprisingly [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Right.
Yeah.
OK.
So this is really in
the context of-- I mean,
they wrote down a model
where they did basically have
something like this, where
they said there's some--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: That's right.
And in particular the
predator, I think,
was not really
dying on it's own.
Except for the dilution.
So it's really the dilution rate
from the chemostat gave them c.
And they could see that indeed,
the rotifer wasn't dying much.
And then a is telling
you about what
happens if you don't
have the rotifer,
you don't have the predator.
And then at that
dilution rate, you
ask what the division rate is.
And that's essentially
the growth rate
of that prey population
minus the dilution
rate of the chemostat.
I'd say that they had these
parameters pretty well.
Yes.
And what they saw experimentally
was that it took much longer.
I mean, the period was
5 times, 10 times longer
than what they
would have expected
based on the measured parameters
for the predator and the prey.
And of course, that
was annoying for them,
because they're actually
doing the experiments.
So they had to do these
chemostat experiments that
lasted six months or
something like that, in order
to see a couple oscillations.
And so this longer period
wasn't just a mathematical--
I'm sure that they were
disappointed to see
these really long time-scale
oscillations, because it was
something that made it
very difficult for them
to do the measurements.
But this is what they
saw experimentally.
And they didn't know
what was causing it.
But they later then
did more modeling
where they asked, which
of the assumptions
in our original model
might not be true.
And the nature of
these things is
that there are an
infinite number
of things are true that are
not incorporated in the model.
And this makes it
quite challenging
to isolate what the
effects might be.
But at the very least what
they can do is they can go in.
And they have some
sense of their system.
And they can make
guesses of what
might have been the
primary things missing.
And then they kind of
went through the models
and they asked,
well, if we kind of
change this assumption
or that assumption,
what does it do in terms
of the oscillations.
And then what they found
in a modeling paper--
so this is their previous
experimental paper before this.
What they found in
their models was
that prey evolution was
kind of the one thing
that if they allowed
prey evolution, i.e.
If they allowed
different types of prey
in their prey
population that might
be oscillating
independently, then they
could get both of these effects.
So from the models
they concluded
that prey evolution
could give this,
could maybe explain
those two things.
These are the two
experimental features.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It might
be that you have
[INAUDIBLE] symantic point.
If you have two types of
species, pre-species--
[INAUDIBLE] they have
these characteristics
and they're not evolving.
They're just fixed.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: You would
still be able to--
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
Right.
This is a major--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yes.
You can argue about what you
want to call evolution and not
revolution.
Over these time scales what
they are not looking at
is the de novo kind of emergence
of new mutants spreading
in the population.
What they're looking at
is variations in say,
different types of prey.
AUDIENCE: So is that what
we would call evolution?
PROFESSOR: Well, OK.
This is a major question.
I think different people call
evolution different things.
And in particular
there's a distinction
between the ecologists and
the evolutionary biologists,
or evolutionary
microbiologists, or whatnot.
And this is something that
I certainly encounter.
For the experimental
microbial evolution guys,
I'd say that for them, if you
use the word "evolution," what
they really want to
see, or what they're
expecting to see is kind
of new mutants arising
in the population,
spreading, fixing,
and that changes the
character of the population.
Whereas from that
standpoint of ecologists--
and indeed, if you look up
the definition of evolution,
it's some change in allele
frequency over time.
And this could certainly be
a change allele frequency
over time in the sense that you
could imagine this arising just
from, for example, there
could be a point mutation
in some gene that leads it
to do something or another.
And in this paper
they didn't identify
exactly what was going on.
I'll tell you a little bit
about a later paper where
they get a better sense of it.
But at least you could
imagine it being the case
that there's just a point
mutation, some gene that
has some fitness defect in
the absence of the predator,
but then allows the algae to
avoid the predator in some way.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: That's right.
That's right.
As far as the model
goes, it could
be that the prey are
really-- one species was just
a point mutation.
Then you'd say, oh yeah.
That's kind of evolution.
Or it could be two different
prey populations and so forth.
Right?
And depending upon what
information you have access to,
you would either be aware
of these things or not.
In this case, they just
look under the microscope
and say, oh yeah, this looks
like an algae, or whatnot.
And maybe they know that
it's the same species.
But they could be different
in lots of different ways.
And I think this
discussion is highlighting
that a lot of the same effects
that you see in ecology also
you see in evolution
and vice versa.
And depending upon
your focus, you
might want to put it more
in the bin of evolution
or in terms of
population dynamics.
I think that's a matter of
taste at some point, actually.
Yeah.
Because they say
rapid evolution.
And I think--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, right.
So I think that
different people will
have different takes on this.
I think, once again,
this is really
very much from the
standpoint of an ecologist,
this is rapid evolution.
Because every cycle, the
allele frequency is changing.
And that's what's
maybe leading to this.
But the thing is,
it's very easy for you
to read certainly the
title, and come away
thinking it's something
different from what it was.
I agree.
But one of the things I
like about this whole line
of research that took place over
the course of say, 15 years,
was that they did these
nice measurements.
They're guided by models.
They saw some things
that they were expecting,
some things they
couldn't explain.
And then they went
and did more modeling.
And then they could explain it.
And that guided this experiment.
Because before what
they did is they just
took kind of the sludge,
or whatever, from the lake.
So there were many
different types
of algae and of the
rotifer, for that matter.
And then they looked at the
predator/prey oscillations
between those.
And then in this
paper what they did
is they took individual
prey populations that
came from a single prey.
So they were kind of isogenic.
Of course eventually they would
evolve, and blah, blah, blah.
But in this case they
took individual isolates
from the prey.
And then what they saw is that
these two features went away.
The oscillation period was
more what they were expecting.
And they got the 90
degree phase lag.
So it's was really a
case of these models
led to the experiments where
they took kind of clonal prey.
And then they recovered
their classical predictions.
And indeed, they've recently
done some other measurements
that I think were quite nice.
They had an ecology letters
paper just a couple years ago
where what they did is they
took two different algae that
had different types embodying
these trade-offs that we
were talking about.
In particular, one of the
algae can divide rapidly.
But it kind of
exists as singles.
Another algae is kind of clumpy.
So this algal type was
able to divide more rapidly
than this algal type.
But this type was harder to
eat just because it was clumpy.
OK?
It's one of things that once
you hear it, you say, oh yeah.
Sure.
But then in the abstract,
when you read this 2003 paper,
you think, oh, I can't
imagine what kind of behavior
could possibly help the
algae avoid these rotifers.
But then in this ecology
letters paper, what they did
is they actually tracked
population densities
of this type, this type, and
of the rotifer over time.
So then they could see all three
sub-populations oscillating.
So then you can
really kind of see
how this evolution, if you
want, or you could just say it's
ecology.
Because it could be different
species for all we care.
But in any case, it's certainly
prey heterogeneity anyway you
look at it.
Whether it's
evolution or ecology.
It's heterogeneity in
the prey population that
leads to these
very qualitatively
different population
oscillations.
Any other questions
on that before we--
And so just for the
last few minutes
I'll say something
about this question
of noise-induced oscillations.
This is going to
be something you're
going to be playing
with over the next week.
So you'll be experts eventually.
And the discussion
in the homework
is really guided by this
paper by McKane and Newman.
All right.
So McKane.
Newman.
McKane is a professor
at Manchester.
And what they showed is that
if you take this model here,
did this model have
limit cycle oscillations,
sustained oscillations?
No.
So this model where we
include the carrying
capacity of the
prey, this does not
have sustained oscillations.
So you take a model like this
that just has a stable spiral.
Now this is a model in
the context of-- it's
a differential equation model.
Now the question is, how
do you incorporate noise?
Just the fact that
individuals give birth,
they die at random times.
The first order way that we
often think to do this is we
just add some noise on to
the differential equations.
So what we do is, you might say,
oh well, you could add some a
to x, and some a to y.
Maybe this noise should be
proportional to x or something.
So you could think about
the strength of this
might be some pre-factor.
So you could just take kind
of a [INAUDIBLE] approach
where you add noise onto
the differential equations.
And then what you
get is a noisy kind
of path to that fixed point.
The perhaps surprising thing
is that instead of adding noise
to a differential
equation, if instead you
start with the individual
based approach,
and you take kind
of a master equation
approach where you say
they're individuals
and they're doing something.
Individual predators are eating
individual prey, et cetera.
So if instead you take
a master equation,
just like what we
did for the chemical
equations modeling
the cells and so forth
that we talked about at
the beginning of the class,
if you formulate this
predator/prey system
as an underlying set of kind of
individual based interactions,
then what you actually find is
that you get surprisingly large
sustained oscillations.
So you really end
up with a situation
where this thing comes.
And it's noisy, of course.
But it kind of comes
around here in some way
that looks like this.
And you'll see this in your
simulations next week where--
and I don't know if you
can see this at all.
But this is some plots
of predator and prey
at reasonably large numbers,
where you can actually
have 1,000 predator or prey.
Somehow you can get some
sort of resonant enhancement
of these oscillations.
And kind of what's
going on is that
the demographic fluctuations
of the demographic noise
excites the system
at all frequencies.
But then there is a
characteristic frequency
given basically
by this frequency
of the inherent
oscillation there
that is somehow amplified.
So you end up with
a situation where
you get these oscillations.
And they're noisy and whatnot.
But it's really because it's
this particular frequency that
was amplified.
And just because it takes
a long time for those
oscillations to go away.
So you can imagine that the
amplitude of the oscillation
falls off as kind of
a root end scaling,
because it's kind of a
demographic type noise.
So it is true that
the relative amplitude
of these oscillations,
it gets larger as you
to smaller population sizes.
But it still ends up being
a surprisingly large effect.
And you'll see how this plays
out in this model that's
basically guided by this paper.
And this was a PRL in 2005.
Incidentally, other
people have since
studied how these
sorts of ideas can
result in noise-induced
pattern formation, as well.
All right, with that,
I will let you guys go.
Have a good Thanksgiving.
I'll see you guys on Tuesday.